lunch money time
that was not supposed to be part of
washington's trying to get rich the rest
is trying to get our lunch money right
paulina what do we got today
who's got two girlfriends come on let's
go what do we got today
okay employers posted a record 11.5
million job openings in march meaning
that the u.s now has an unprecedented
two job openings for every person who is
unemployed
if we think about this
okay good what's your question my
question is i thought that the stimulus
and all that stuff like was over why
aren't people getting jobs now no they
have jobs that's why unemployment's so
low oh it's like like we're putting
people in an economic pretzel here
mentally
11.5 million open jobs normally would be
if there's that many open jobs they'll
be really really high unemployment right
but instead
everyone already went back to work we
have really low unemployment but high
job openings which means we don't have
enough people to fill all the jobs and
part of that is because one technology
right the second thing though is that
there's a lot of people who got jobs
that don't count as jobs so i used to
work at a factory now i'm on tick tock
that's my new job factory job is open
there's no one to take it on top of that
you then look and say okay tick tock's a
little extreme what about the instagram
models what about the podcasters what
about all the people who are just like
you know what yolo i'm gonna be invest
in my portfolio there's all kinds of
things that people are doing to make
income now that may not count as a
quote-unquote job in the sense of
filling the open roles on top of that
all that stimulus led to massive growth
massive growth in these companies meant
that they had more and more job openings
so what you get is 11.5 million open
jobs now the more important point for
you sitting at home watching this if you
don't like your job quit and go find
another one there's eleven and a half
million and guess what in order for them
to get you to apply to their job versus
another job they're jacking up how much
they pay they're jacking up their
compensation they're jacking up the
benefits and they're trying to solicit
you this is how economics and free
markets work if there's a lot of supply
of open rolls how do you elicit demand
well if they offer ten dollars an hour
nobody applies nobody fills the role so
then they got offered twelve then
fifteen then seventeen then eighteen
then twenty that's why mcdonald's is
offering twenty dollars an hour that's
why eighty percent of americans now make
more than fifteen dollars an hour it's
because there is massive supply of open
rules and they have to continue to
increase that economic uh incentive to
get you to go fill the role so
if you ain't got a raise in the last two
years hit the exit door go get another
job or if you just don't like the people
you work with see ya are there
are there stats around like
entrepreneurship and how many people
started their own thing during the
pandemic in 2020 was one of the largest
years on record of new job app or a new
business applications
because a bunch of people got laid off
like oh [ __ ] i gotta get some money so
they start businesses so what ends up
happening is uh from an economic
standpoint during 2020 even in 2021 in
the bad times tons of great businesses
are built because necessity is the
mother of invention so people are
sitting there saying damn i need to get
a job i need to get money to feed my
family so i have to create a business
what's interesting is as asset prices
have sold off over the last three four
five months
everybody's scared there's blood in the
streets people like the world's ending
the world ain't ending guess what the
people that are investing right now
who are like i don't care about
short-term price i'm just looking at the
long-term they're going to be just
deploying capital f
that entrepreneurs are building right
now they are likely to go get
massive benefit over time and the reason
why is because if you go back to 2018
and remember the crypto bear market yes
there was literally
best-in-class world record returns
that were derived from people who
started investing in 2018. it's always
constrained and hard times make good
times yeah you know you know what they
say i don't like the circle pressure
pressure makes diamonds
oh i do like that okay
um
yeah that's a good one elon musk
funding almost secured no funding
security no almost no funding security
not all of it yeah funding security no
yeah i'm positive all right well does he
have okay so elon so okay so
this is interesting larry ellison
sequoia the vc farm crypto exchange
binance
they're all
supporting elon musk's 44 billion dollar
takeover of twitter and the sec filing
shows that musk has secured 7.14 billion
in total you're saying the rest no so
the way the deal's coming together is
there's 44 billion dollar purchase price
that's like the the price tag 44 billion
of that uh i don't know the exact
numbers but about half let's call it 22
billion or so is loans those loans are
coming from morgan stanley and a number
of other places some of them are loans
against the actual revenues of twitter
some of them are loans using uh tesla
stock as collateral some of them are
probably unsecured loans etc so there's
about half of the deal is coming from uh
debt the other half about 22 billion or
so is equity meaning that people are
gonna put up the capital elon being a
boss he sat and he said i'm gonna pay
all 22 billion myself unless other
people want to join me and of course
rich people around the world hey elon
can i join can i get in the game and so
about 7.1 billion of the 22 billion ish
is now being committed by other people
this is andreessen horowitz sequoia
uh larry ellison putting a billion
dollars personally in uh binance putting
in 500 million dollars et cetera so what
ends up occurring is now elon is able to
get some partners and start putting in
less and less of his money so he's going
from 22 billion to like 14 or 15 billion
now and over time my guess is that he'll
probably if i had to guess just
complete uneducated uh stab in the air
here about 10 billion dollars either
i'll put him personally so there'll be a
couple more people that show up and say
hey i want to put money in whatever and
so elon ends up putting in about 25 of
the deal in equity capital he's got
partners to fill out another call at 25
or so and then 50 of his debt he'll be
able to buy 44 billion dollars and
what's interesting is saudi prince allah
we'd been telling
of
[Music]
who is already he's already an investor
on twitter and initially rejected musk
steel has pledged to buy 34 million 900
shares worth around 1.7 billion
do you want me to read his name again no
but but if i was elon i'd reject it
but oh you rejected my uh my offer watch
me reject your cash
also interesting qatar they're
participating a number of other uh
middle eastern folks are pledging money
uh and so they're this is gonna this is
gonna get uh it's gonna get plus yeah
the critics again whether you agree with
them or not the credit scores say hey if
you're doing this for free speech
purposes but you're taking money from uh
various folks around the world not just
in the middle east but around the world
if they've got a great track record on
free speech or they don't people are
going to go and argue that like there
are some people who i would say you know
the united states may not have a great
great track record on free speech canada
definitely don't have a great track
record on free speech lately and so you
start to look at this as like if a
canadian pension fund was to invest in
this deal would the critics have
ammunition to be like you took money
from the canadian pension funds and
canada is not a bastion of free speech i
think it's surprising that nobody's
talking about that oh they're talking
about it on twitter you're just not
paying attention to the twitter feed i
got
yours is like they got roses and
rainbows over there on your twitter feed
on my twitter feed everyone's out with
the intellectual weapons just having a
war my twitter feed is like a bunny and
a meadow yeah exactly and mine there's
just literally the skulls and bodies of
intellectual death everywhere after
people just been dunking on each other
okay next
i like don't come into mind if you're
scolding someone goosey
i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking i knew
i'd get it though gucci hit me with the
gucci house of gucci
i watched the documentary on the plane
you did not yeah house of gucci it's a
great it's a fictionalized version based
on truth
yeah house of gucci
and did you know did you know
that he had a crazy uncle
and they screwed him over
the guy in the movie
he had a crazy uncle pablo gucci and he
said this is my company too
and they were like not really you're out
i don't know what story house of gucci
go ahead gucci is tapping into the
crypto crowd the brand will accept
cryptocurrency payments in some u.s
stores at the end of this month and
plans to extend the pilot to all of its
directly operated north american stores
this summer the move marks a major
validation for the currency from a
leading luxury brand the most surprising
thing about this is that vogue business
broke this story anyway no to be clear
this does not validate anything bitcoin
does not care about gucci crypto does
not care about gucci gucci people
what do you mean
this is this hat no you know what this
is this is like 17 months of uh
conference meetings where everyone is
going into a room like let's be
innovative let's be innovative let's be
honest this is innovative it's
innovative
innovative and and they're walking in if
you're a gucci you don't speak normal
you speak rich people innovation no you
say things rich like uh finance you
don't say finance you say finance
harvard like that's what you say right
like yeah
yeah they're like uh we should uh be
innovative at harvard and then that's
how they talk but when they're there
guess what they're doing they're like
what is something that we could do that
would make us look innovative and what
ends up being is like let's accept
crypto like yo you all three years late
if you wanted to be innovative you
should have done that three years ago we
on to the next thing and so gucci here's
a big one for you all you people out
there who into these luxury brands gucci
they on the back of the train you know
who's at the front of the train lvmh
lvmh they own tiffany's tiffany's they
gave it to the uh bernard or not son i
don't know or no son he he's all in he's
so far ahead that gucci's lost in the
sauce that's what's going on right now
tiffany's they got jay-z they got uh
beyonce they got all sorts of different
uh athletes on board they are doing nfts
they're into crypto
they're the leader but why is it a bad
thing i think it's a good thing if it's
just it's just a footnote now it doesn't
matter
but doesn't it help that you can
actually transact and buy things gucci
needs
bitcoin or crypto more than bitcoin or
crypto needs gucci first but isn't it
good for the overall ecosystem it's like
saying gucci's now accepting money like
congratulations way to get on the way to
get on the uh
uh on the platform there have you ever
bought anything from gucci gucci i've
been to gucci
i walked in gucci one time uh what what
is the place in l.a
oh yeah what is that kenny no no no no
abby kitty that's that that is a poor
man's rodeo drive abbot kitty is a poor
man's robot you drove to la one time
yeah and you didn't like it but rodeo
drive that's the place i was thinking i
look at my big brain here remember in
the place abbott kinney watered down
version of rodeo drive rodeo drive they
got gucci there i walked in the gucci
place when i was with my mom my mom went
she literally grabbed the uh uh what
they call like house shoes slides
whatever uh gucci slippers whatever yeah
but they were like kind of
weird ones and of course gucci and i
looked at the price tag i literally said
i gotta go
it was like four thousand dollars i was
like
is wearing 4 000 slippers um
you if you wear four thousand dollar
slippers
you just like money on fire that's what
you do like you're like oh you wanna
have a fire in the backyard all right go
get the cash you just put it in there
just light it on fire to stay wasn't
there a meme about like all these
finance bros in new york wearing gucci
loafers i'm sure
listen if you work at a wall street bank
and you wear gucci uh loafers you're
going nowhere in life how do you know
well it's pretty simple because you
don't make enough money to actually be
wearing gucci loafers and have money
left over it's you're more worried about
the materialistic things and how you
look than you are about actually getting
rich because if you
were actually balling you wouldn't be
working at the bank for somebody else
that hey listen i just say the facts
people can get mad but
any time i see somebody and they walk
around they're like oh look at my six
thousand dollar shoes i'm like cool you
gonna wear the six thousand dollar shoes
to go to the office to do the slides for
the other guy all right i got you like
we we cool we gucci you're so crazy
all right so
orbital assembly corporation is planning
to build voyager station and pioneer
station to space hubs in the sky and
it's a basically a space hotel scheduled
to open in 2025. would you go
to space hotel yeah space hotel
to get away from you that's fine you'd
be like damn he's so good he's out of
this world
you guys
you're ruining my mojo go ahead so
basically it's scheduled to accommodate
400 people and to open 2027.
although the headline says 2025.
freaking cnn i'm i can't i think it is
every time every time you get it say cnn
is that 20 27 or 20. no say cnn is fake
news so we can click no this is wrong
news
that is fake news it
now scheduled so either 25 or 27
somebody in the comments molina's based
she's based
somebody in the comments can fact check
me please nah go ahead so i would go to
the space hotel
if you could go to the hotel stay for a
couple days and come back then you're
ready to roll but this is just a larger
trend of like space tourism i think it's
going to explode i think but it's real
space this isn't fake space bezos with
the face fake space this is real space
yeah you're up there no gravity whole
situation not just like i'm gonna go up
there for an hour and come back down
like that's just a hot air balloon ride
but what's if you're gonna go to space
why would you stay at a hotel
well what do you think the iss is they
call it the iss so it's sound smart it
but it's just a hotel for nurses
if you think that's what they're doing
it's a hotel for nerds or a hotel for
astronauts wait taylor stewart said pump
prefers fox news is that correct
exactly
he's very i literally think all of these
news stations are stupid
msnbc dumb fox news dumb cnn dumb
they're all dumb like if you if you're
sitting there this is how you know that
you're being tricked if you think that
there's a real line in the sand and that
you stand on one side and the people on
the other side of the line are stupid no
you're a fool like there is no line
we're all humans they're just trying to
make you guys all argue with each other
get out the game step back be like nine
playing this game
you all ain't tricking me you ain't
tricking me there's no way there's no
way that uh the divisiveness that is
drawn by all the extremes of these uh uh
legacy media companies just just don't
participate it's like if you see two
people are fighting on the street what
are the most intelligent rational people
always try to help you can help
you could be like hey stop fighting
but nobody jumps in he's like yeah
like that's just not what happened all
right just a very quick side note story
side note story one time we were walking
down the street and i got second hand
pepper sprayed that that did happen yeah
there was bobby two bodies on the ground
i was like we're gonna be ours i was
like this is miami like this is exactly
what i picture well i just wanna tell
you very very quickly what happened was
one uh uh doordash slash uber food drive
or whatever and another one they got an
argument and as we were walking down the
sidewalk all of a sudden we saw somebody
go like this and then another guy
grabbed his eye and like ran away and i
literally thought he got stabbed so i
like pushed pulling i got pushed
to try to keep you safe and i went to
push her out of the way in the line of
fire it took like three more steps
forward and then all of a sudden we got
hit with it and you know i cuz i
understand what pepper spray is i am
trained to withstand the pepper spray
was fun and i'm like
itching but you were freaking out and
then i was like oh [ __ ] and she was
pregnant at the time i was like oh
so i went to the restaurant and got a
glass of water for and i was like here's
a glass of water i'm a good husband so
it was in the middle of all these drunk
people me sipping water yeah that's fine
okay all right nobody's gonna say that
uh instead of drinking the water i got
you the water to put it on your eyeballs
but if that's secondhand purpose right i
cannot imagine
garth so okay so louisiana isn't exactly
known for its earthquakes right
okay but during garth brook's saturday
night concert at lsu's tiger stadium
over a hundred thousand fans danced and
sang so hard that a cis sesmograph on
campus registered a small earthquake
people love star trucks
it's not an earthquake what do you mean
no no no earthquake is when the tectonic
plates shift
that is an earthquake
what this is is just the earth shaking
that's different that's an earthquake no
it's not
no earthquake comes from like underneath
the earth from the crust but you took
science class in third grade it's when
the crust is moving and it causes a
fracturing and then there's a shaking of
the earth it's a internal to external
shock this
is some fools actually garth brook's
pretty cool so i'm in for him uh dancing
around on the ground that's a external
situation that's an earth shake not an
earthquake oh that's an earth shake
hey listen if y'all want science class i
can just teach you science all day do
you know what the earth's cross is made
out of yes lava no it's not made out of
jesus christ okay
you have 1 minute 55 seconds go ahead
wait wait do you remember that um in
fourth grade we watched that thing i
didn't know you in fourth grade fritz
fritz what was it called guys what are
you talking about when they go in the
earth
look at that big brain i got right there
that's where i learned about the earth
and the light no you didn't learn
anything because you didn't know what
the crust wasn't made out of what's
what's the inside ball called the inside
ball yeah
the core yeah no matter
it's like an avocado court millennials
ain't ever getting confused about the
core they all eat avocados they know
exactly how the earth works don't worry
on top of that real quick on top of that
you ever play the game when you were a
kid you stayed on the couch don't lose
this comment the foot the floor the
floor is lava and then you don't step on
the floor you play that game steven said
paulina is literally the cutest sweetest
human ever pumped do not take that girl
for granted you tell him stephen
i know you paid him i literally did not
oh frizzle miss frizzle not friends yeah
see people
pumped it and go to fourth grade with
you
let's just get it clear like what
remember in fourth grade one week no i
don't remember we didn't go to school
together in fact i was so smart i
skipped third grade also didn't know
english
i'm not gonna touch that it wasn't
because i was smart okay um what am i
what am i doing oh yeah it's lunch money
time no it's ask lunch money it's ask
lunch money time hashtag ask them in the
comments below or in the separate lunch
money video i'm trying to explain the
instructions for 25 seconds okay the
question is this is for you from connor
chapenic
he said just found out i'm gonna be a
dad last week congratulations connor
welcome to the rest of your life why did
i do this any advice for keeping your
significant other happy during pregnancy
well i have three things before we get
to the advice the first thing is once
you become a dad you're always a dad so
like welcome to the rest of your life
the second thing is that your first kid
will never have a better dad than you so
you're good there uh and then the third
thing is that when you have the kid you
could always blame the kid for anything
you do moving forward so like if i
forget to leave something uh put
something away and leave it out at the
house uh what i end up saying to pelina
is uh oh sophia left that i don't know
why she did that i'll teach her to do
better next time that's fine uh but if
we think about this uh my best advice is
uh actually comes from our friend uh ali
oh that is good advice our friend ali
who uh one time said to me i figured out
uh relationships and it was me pulling
at him and uh he did figure out his now
wife and i said
okay if you're going if you're going to
volunteer some relationship advice in
this uh this shark circle i would love
to hear it and uh
he said the best key
to relationships
is to be supportive not helpful
and i thought that was a great piece of
advice so don't try to solve the problem
you're not going to solve the problem
if she is like if you want i want
pickles
what you could say is
wow i want pickles too and then don't
try to go get the pickles because you
make a yell after going to get the
pickles just just be supportive oh you
don't feel good ah man i feel so bad for
you i feel bad too maybe together we
feel bad together like one time i had a
mental breakdown because i asked them to
go get me cheetos like the the skinny
ones and he came back with the puffs
oh and i was just not happy
i was like let me tell you the other
side of this story let me tell you the
other side of this story i went down
i went down
from the apartment got up off my ass
i actually had to put socks and shoes on
and i think a t-shirt oh shirtless at
the time i got a t-shirt on i went
downstairs i went to the corner store
and i swear to god
i stood in front of the cheetos rack
yeah and i said to myself i'm wrong
no matter which one i
and so you know what i said
i got a 50 50 shot there was the puffs
and there was the skinny ones and i
thought about buying both but i was like
nah she's gonna know that i don't know
what she likes and so i just took a 50
50 shot and then when i went upstairs
and i gave her the one and she was like
these are the wrong ones you know what i
hit her with the other ones were out
i did eat the whole bag of puffs anyway
in the comments please tell us skinny or
puffs okay oh
the other ones are out
that's not funny it was pretty funny to
me all right make sure that you leave a
comment on this video we'll go ahead and
take questions tomorrow ask lunch money